good morning everyone welcome to the key
school into the Annapolis Book Festival
2016 my name is John bead and I'll be
the moderator for today's fantastic
opening panel entitled American Dream
American greed just a quick reminder to
please mute your cellphone's because I
think you'll want to be tuned in to
everything our our great panelists have
to say this morning all right just a
couple of quick intros I'm a foreign
service officer with the US Agency for
International Development I'm currently
assigned to the faculty at the National
Defense Industry National Defense
University
I'm flanked not only by two great books
but really two stellar authors to my
right Bethany McLean
she's a contributing editor at Vanity
Fair a columnist at fortune and also
contributes to CNBC she co-authored the
smartest guys in the room about the
colossal fall of the energy trading
giant Enron but more important than that
she actually foretold it a few years
earlier when she started asking
questions is Enron overvalued and is it
transparent so actually when she says
there may be another issue brewing we
probably ought to sit up and take listen
to my left is Ben Strauss a very
talented contributing writer to the New
York Times he's written extensively an
in-depth on college athletics were
really much more important than that
he's really dived into the the very rich
and multi-dimensional human interest
stories behind college athletes and
athletes around the world actually he's
got my son's dream job frankly my dream
job so it's it's really great to have
you here and thank you both for coming
to this year's Annapolis Book Festival
American Dream American greed you know
it's a very provocative title and I
think today we're in for a real we're in
for a real treat
we're going to try to have a very
lively 30-minute discussion and then I'm
going to try to leave room for about
10-15 minutes of audience questions
before we break and we have a hard stop
because of c-span - today at 10:50 -
kick us off you know the both of your
books are so well conveyed and really so
captivating I'd like to ask each of you
to kind of kick us off with maybe a two
to three minute elevator ride to the top
what's one of the major points in your
books and you know what do you have to
say about them I'm gonna start with
Bethany
before I do shaky ground is the title
you know it's very timely today and this
week unfortunately Japan is in the news
again a very severe earthquake on the
island of kyushu in 2011 I was in Tokyo
for the big earthquake there which
touched off tsunamis and a nuclear
emergency that they're still trying to
deal with 2008 our global financial
system melted down eight years later
bethenny says were still on shaky ground
why Bethany so I'm always been
fascinated by these two large companies
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac they're
collectively the largest financial
institution in the world with over five
trillion dollars of outstanding
liabilities and these two companies were
created to serve the American dream of
homeownership to help enable the flow of
mortgage credit in the United States and
it's funny because most people even in
the financial world don't really care
about Fannie and Freddie they're part of
the hidden infrastructure of our lives
the things we don't think about until
they malfunction but they're really
critical companies they're critical if
you have a mortgage if you ever want to
get a mortgage because the availability
of mortgage credit helps shape your
ability to finance your house they're
critical to the price of your house and
homes are still the most important
financial asset that most Americans
Americans have and they're actually
critical to our economy way back in the
1920s Franklin Roosevelt's Treasury
secretary described housing as the wheel
within the wheel of our economy and it
is housing makes up some 15 to 20
percent of our gee
so if the housing market isn't healthy
the economy isn't healthy so basically I
feel like everyone should care about the
the strength and the fate of these two
companies and some of you may remember
they were taken over by the US
government in the fall of 2008 and put
into a state called conservatorship
where they were basically operated by
the US government and supported by a
line of credit from the Treasury and the
idea was this was going to be temporary
we were going to figure out a way to
resolve this and instead here we sit
going on eight years from the date
Fannie and Freddie were taken over and
they still sit as Ward's of the US
government someone told me it was the
greatest example of government
dysfunction he's ever seen and while
that may be an exaggeration given some
of what's going on in Washington
nonetheless the point the point the
point probably holds and under a
decision the government made there being
drained of all their capital and the
profits that they produce are being used
basically to cover the budget deficit
and the problem with that is in the wake
of the financial crisis the big idea has
been get more capital into financial
institutions in the whole system will be
safer and we have collectively the
largest financial institution in the
world that instead is being drained of
capital with no real plan for its future
for their futures and I think that
leaves all of us in a somewhat
precarious position thank you well that
leaves me with even greater unease and
when I read the book maybe Ben can give
us some more happy happy news but I
doubt it
his book is entitled indentured really
the inside story of how a few people
took on the NCAA and the end justices
and the inequities and in college
athletics and how the multi-billion
dollar industry is kind of where it goes
and who gets it you know I have to kind
of make a confession here when I before
I read Ben's book I was very much on the
side that said hey college athletes
they're getting a great free education
why do they need to get paid they're not
employees but I have to tell you you
know that line and Jerry Maguire where
you know they say the Tom Cruise or she
says the Tom Cruise you had me at hello
we then you added me at page two and I'm
not that easy
indentured Cartel Gestapo mafia some
people in the book are compared to J
Edgar Hoover and even Darth Vader is is
this fair and and why so harsh Ben yes
sadly I think I have more bad news to
follow Bethenny's so good morning
everybody
I think you can break up the the
problems with college sports there's
there's sort of three buckets and the
first is the money college sports is a
thirteen billion dollar industry now so
that if you can believe it is is more
money than the NFL brings in so this is
a lot of money and there's coaches that
are making five million dollars and ten
million dollars there are conferences
where in ACC country but I guess we're
also in Big Ten country now because
Maryland is in the big ten conferences
they all own TV networks now and they
make between two and three hundred
million dollars a year they the the men
who lead the conference's have three
million dollar salaries most of the
coaches four or five million dollar
salaries and of all of this money
players you know the ones driving the
revenue driving the interest see what
amounts to less than a sliver of this so
you have this financial dichotomy the
second piece is that the NCAA has a 400
page rulebook that basically governs
every aspect of of a college athletes
life it tells you how many times you can
eat at somebody's house you know who you
can accept a ride from if you are a
college athlete and you want to transfer
schools you have to get the NCAA's
permission you have to get your coach's
permission and whereas the adults in the
room can leave school no problem and so
the way the rules are applied to the
kids the the athletes and and the adults
is is is wildly disparate and and the
third thing is what is supposed to make
all of this okay as John mentioned is
the scholarship this college education
so yes we have a lot of money
yes there are rule a lot of rules but
this is all okay because we're educating
these athletes and that's what college
sports are about well unfortunately that
isn't quite the case because federal
graduation rates for football and men's
basketball players are about 50% anybody
that has seen the news about what
happened at North Carolina over the last
20 years where these athletes were
funneled into classes literally fake
classes that the university knew about
that the athletic department knew about
they did not meet that classes did not
exist and they were meant to keep the
athletes eligible at other schools you
have majors like Fitness studies that
the big-time athletes are clustered into
and so the idea that they're getting a
meaningful education or any education at
all is is sort of fiction and harkens
back to a mythological college sports
and an NCAA that that might have been
around in the 1970s but is not anymore
and so you know between the rights that
are taken away and the education that
it's not delivered and the financial
dichotomy that exists you have a system
that ends up being you know there's no
other word for it then it's expletive
all of us I think love as Americans all
people we love authenticity
we also recoil at hypocrisy hypocrisy is
a threat I see actually in both your
books and you mentioned it explicitly
then could you talk a little bit about
how it seems like the NCAA beyond being
just arbitrary really kind of picking
and choosing who gets rewarded and who
gets the blame or who gets punished
could you talk a little bit about that
well I don't think you have to look any
further everybody knows the term student
athlete we've all heard this yes this is
ingrained in the fabric of America the
fabric of higher education in college
and the word was made up by the first
executive director of the NCAA and
precisely because there was a football
player at a school in Texas who got hurt
playing and his family requested workers
compensation benefits because here he
was doing a job for the school he was an
employee and as soon as he got hurt he
was entitled to workers comp and this
terrified people at the NCAA terrified
people across college sports and what
did they do they invented the word
student-athlete embedded it in all of
the NCAA's literature schools had to
call the player student athletes
broadcasters on TV had to call them
student athletes and it was nothing more
than a marketing ploy to avoid paying
out workers compensation and it has
worked fabulously but I don't think that
there's a more obvious example of
hypocrisy than sort of this word that is
treasured in the United States today and
treasured by by colleges and by college
sports but its origins and its roots are
far more nefarious than then we would
realize how about the markets Bethenny
it you know we've all heard the
expression too big to fail or are there
some companies are there some banks that
are way too connected to fail I I know
you don't cherish your time working at
Goldman Sachs I'm told but I wonder if
that gives you some perspective on on
you know why it is regulators and the
government allow some banks to be saved
and others not and there's been a pretty
common thread from Goldman am i seeing a
boogeyman here but is that why aarg was
was saved it's a big question so I
worked at Goldman way back at the
beginning of my career from 92 to 95 I
was basically at the janitor level so I
can't pretend any great insight into the
workings of our financial system from
that but I but I
learn not to be afraid of financial
concepts and I guess not to be
intimidated by people in business
I think Goldman is probably an easy
buggy man but I think the buggy the real
boogeyman is probably is probably much
much much larger than that there there
is this back in the beginning days of
our country we were always scared about
the power of big financial institutions
there was a lot of rhetoric about we
could never be a nation that had big
financial institutions because of our
fear of the power that those those
financial institutions could could could
have and one of the really odd things
about the financial crisis is that for
all the rhetoric about too big to fail
and how institutions had grown too big
and too powerful to fail we came out of
the financial crisis with institutions
that were were even bigger and people
will tell you that they are now much
safer that we've put in place all sorts
of new rules and regulations that will
that have that have fixed all the
problems I tend to be a little bit
skeptical perhaps from having been
around for a while and perhaps from just
having a negative contrary and
personality about whether we've really
fixed the problems and one of the things
I always I always look to in the wake of
Enron we passed a law called
sarbanes-oxley
and when President George Bush signed
this law called SAR sarbanes-oxley in
the Rose Garden he talked about how now
our financial markets were safe and we'd
put in place all sorts of things that
had made ordinary people protected and
investors could believe they would never
be tricked again in the future so a few
years later down the pike comes the
financial crisis and you had President
Obama sign a law called dodd-frank
in the Rose Garden and if you compare
his speech to President Bush's speech
upon the signing of sarbanes-oxley
they're remarkably similar and the the
similarities are quite quite depressing
at the school where I teach it's called
the Dwight D Eisenhower school Ike
Eisenhower warned about the
military-industrial complex
bethenny has a chapter in a book called
the housing industrial complex is is
this housing industrial complex first of
all what is it and is it something we
need to fear as much as the middle
pterri industrial complex well perhaps
in some ways so my perspective on Fannie
and Freddie these two giant companies is
a little bit I think the tone of the
book is a little bit how I learned to
love the GSE is but I want to back up to
that idea of the housing industrial
complex this there's this notion of the
American Dream as home ownership is this
thing that makes our country a better
society and it's ingrained deeply in our
in our society if you go back to the
1800s that was part of the concept that
a nation of landowners would make us
safer stronger more cohesive society but
Fannie and Freddie during their heyday
were immensely powerful institutions and
immensely politically powerful
institutions and they managed to take
this concept of home ownership and make
it a way a way to make a lot of money
because you actually couldn't challenge
the notion of home ownership if you
challenged Fannie and Freddie and said
they might not be doing the right thing
well you were challenging home ownership
and that more largely writ is also part
of the story of the the financial crisis
because if you had tried to do something
to rein in mortgage credit even though
people were getting all sorts of risky
mortgages while the companies would go
to Congress and say you're hurting
people's homeownership opportunities so
it became an excuse for all sorts of
behavior that actually had nothing to do
with with with homeownership and there's
there's a lot of money at stake the
mortgage market is a ten trillion dollar
market the American mortgage markets one
of the largest bond markets in the world
it's incredibly lucrative everybody
wants a piece of the money and so you
have what people have jokingly not so
jokingly called the housing industrial
complex which is this sort of loosely
knit formidable alliance of all the
people who make money off off off your
homes basically and they've been an
incredibly formidable political
political force in in Washington and
Fannie and Freddie are part of them so a
ten trillion dollar market then you
referred to thirteen billion dollar
industry and college athletics where is
all that money going and as some of it
going for good things to improve our
higher education system
not really
so so of this thirteen billion dollars I
much of it goes to very high coaching
salaries and so when you can't pay the
players the money has to go somewhere
right so it goes into coaching salaries
it goes into administrators salaries the
head coach at Clemson School played for
the national championship last year
the head coach has a chief of staff that
makes two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year the strength coach of
Alabama's football team makes six
hundred thousand dollars a year and so
one of the reasons that they make so
much money is because this money has to
go somewhere and it cannot be given to
the players and the way to recruit the
players is to build you know palatial
facilities and Oregon's football
facility has imported Brazilian wood in
it they imported wood from Brazil to
build this facility and it's gorgeous
and it's you know 4050 million dollars
but that's how you recruit players
because you can't offer them money so
you have to offer them a lot of cool
stuff but another reason that you know
the best coaches that Nick Saban at
Alabama can make seven million dollars
is because when they bring in the best
players
it is a tremendous marketing arm for
school right and so when you hear about
football players that they'd get away
with you know close to but not murder
right they get away with you know
breaking rules and and and mistreating
women it's because they are so valuable
to the school and so you have this
strange dichotomy where these athletes
are both exploited financially and then
coddled with and a lot of you know bad
behavior is is allowed because they are
worth so much to these schools and and
the budgets the athletic school budgets
are almost always separate from the main
college and so very little money ever
goes back to the school it's contained
and it's it's used to to build
facilities and and pay coaches a lot of
money
you know we spend a lot of our time at
the National Defense University teaching
leadership trying to look at kind of
what are some of the successes and
failures of leadership and how we avoid
that in the future in terms of our
students personal leadership development
you know Bethany has has a great quote
actually you know when we look at the
global financial crisis and we look at
the situation that we're in you know the
story of the crisis is often mortgage
backed securities and risk management
tools but you've said the end of the day
the story is really about people with
the Enron crisis you had some pretty
visible faces out there Ken Lay and Jeff
Skilling you had Michael Milken with the
kind of us the face of the excesses in
the 1980s who are the villains now and
are there any heroes it's interesting
I've always thought that business
stories are stories about people they're
stories about human nature and it's one
of the reasons I love covering these
sagas of business gone wrong so much
because their human nature usually at
its worst maybe sometimes at its best
heroes are tricky in the in the
financial crisis my colleague Joe Nocera
who co-authored Ben's book as well and I
titled our book about the financial
crisis all the Devils are here in part
because there is this very human need to
find the one thing to blame the thing
that is the thing that we can say that
villain caused all our pain and if we
just focus on that bill and everything
will be better but it's usually an
oversimplification then particularly in
the in the case of the financial crisis
and all the Devils it's a great line
from Shakespeare hell is empty and all
the devils are here and it refers in my
mind to the very multi-culti causal
nature of the financial crisis it was
lots and lots of things coming together
with lots and lots of villains and we
profiled the rating agencies and Alan
Greenspan and Wall Street executives and
mortgage bankers who lured people into
mortgages that they couldn't afford and
in some cases homeowners who knowingly
took out took out loans that they
couldn't afford complicated are there
any heroes
fraud I think I don't know if any of you
have seen the movie made out of Michael
Lewis's book the big short which is
which is great and it portrays the small
group of people who saw the financial
crisis coming as as heroes and they were
in a way they saw what so many other
people were were unwilling to see but
usually in the financial world
whistleblowers and it come with their
own come with their own story and in
this case these people made a lot of
money from the destruction that the
financial crisis the financial crisis
caused and so too they're they're
ambiguous heroes I suppose I would say
then you actually Chronicle some heroes
in your book people who really stood up
to the n-c-double-a whether it's a group
of players from Northwestern University
the the sneaker guy Sonny Vaccaro and
and others is there one that kind of
stands out to you as kind of a tipping
point I think if there is a main
character in in our book it is Sonny
Vaccaro who is fondly known as the
sneaker pimp because he worked for Nike
in the 1980s and was the first guy to to
figure out that if you pay schools and
coaches to have them wear Nikes to have
the players wear Nikes it helps sell
Nike shoes and so he introduced this
concept that has blossomed and
absolutely exploded since the 1980s he's
also the guy who convinced Nike to pour
a lot of resources into signing Michael
Jordan when he was coming out of North
Carolina and to build a shoe around him
so he is a guy who sort of invented
commercialism in college sports and then
about 15 years ago he had seen so many
players that he had worked with
basically railroaded by the NCAA by the
NCAA's rules and and quit his job he was
a Reebok then and went on a crusade
there's no better word a crusade against
the NCAA he he's the one who ginned up a
federal lawsuit against the NCAA that
went to trial a couple years ago
he toured the country speaking at law
schools you know in front of crowds have
you know 15 20 people trying to explain
the ills of the NCAA in this
off-the-cuff sort of you know he's not a
linear thinker and so you'd go and you'd
hear him speaking and you know you
hadn't to have no idea what he was
saying but you would understand the
passion and and the idea of injustice
that is that sort of guy and and if
there is one main character he he is the
guy this is a little bit more of a
charged question a follow up here Dale
Brown the famous I hate saying famous
because I went to Tulane University and
he's the was the coach of Louisiana
State University our arrival but he
wants like in this all to kind of having
the whiff of a plantation racism how you
know you see a lot of this being played
out on college campuses all over the
country some courageous people at
University of Missouri for one standing
up to how much do you see racism as
having played a role and kind of the
slowness to redress some of the in
justices around the system yeah I think
if you just look at the at what's
happening the the vast majority or the
majority of football and men's
basketball players are black the vast
majority of administrators and coaches
are white and so this is a tremendous
wealth transfer from you know some of
the poorest and most vulnerable in our
society to to what are often
upper-middle class people but if it was
the other way around if you had you know
white people generating a lot of money
that black people were generally reaping
the benefits of would something have
been done a long time ago probably and I
don't think anybody at the NCAA is
thinking you know how you know how do we
you know take money from black people
and give it to white people how that's
not sort of the way it works but at the
same time the rules and the way that the
system
set up you know a lot like you know drug
sentencing you know the rules
objectively are race neutral but they
affect one section of our population far
more than another population it's it's
it's just like that and and so the
effect the effect is that you do have a
tremendous wealth transfer from young
black men to other people on college
campuses and there's absolutely no way
around that
so we're in the middle of a presidential
campaign season if you hadn't noticed
and while it's being dominated by kind
of who can ride the subway better who
has bigger hands and you know the
Twitter Wars they're not talking about
substance
the kind of substance that Bethenny
describes and the kind of concern she
lays out in her book but I want to ask
you have have any of the campaign's
reached out to you do you see any of
them kind of taking an interest and what
you you have to say here that's a really
quick answer there was actually thinking
when Dunn was talking there's a really
interesting theme between our two books
which is this notion of implicit
corruption right it's not that anybody's
intending or really you know try it and
in the same holds true in the business
world it's not that you're always when
you're when you're writing these stories
you're always looking for the moment
where people met in a dark room and
plotted to take down you know Enron and
defraud shareholders and plotted to
destroy the global financial system and
you just wish you could find that
meeting right of the heads of Wall
Street firms and this preferably smoky
bar of Wall Street plotting the
destruction of the global financial
system it never happens there's never
that that that moment in these these
stories are always this weird mixture of
a little bit of outright corruption with
a lot of suspension of disbelief and
it's this notion of implicit corruption
everybody's in on it because that's just
how it's done and everybody thinks
that's everybody's come to take the
system as it is for granted and it
sounds like that's a parallel theme
between our two bucks and sometimes you
wish that there was a smoking gun
because people would pay it people
people want a smoking gun so badly
and and to have people really pay
attention sometimes you need a smoking
gun and then it just it doesn't exist
and so you sort of build a narrative and
it's a lot of you know well obviously
something's going on here but without
the smoking gun you don't have sort of
this moment where everybody goes oh of
course right or this moment of
absolutely conscious willful deception
and and and and wrongdoing and our human
search for narrative we want that
turning point to hang the story on and
so I think it always makes these stories
somewhat unsatisfying on one level
although on another level they're a much
deeper very human story right because
that usually is the story of how things
go wrong is a whole lot of self-delusion
wrapped up with a little bit of greed
wrapped up but maybe a little bit about
right corruption well so nobody's
focused on these issues now and it seems
to take a smoking gun to really get
action but what's up what's a possible
way forward to try to fix Fannie and
Freddie Mac before it happens again well
it's a really complicated question
because on the surface you want to say
well just let's just get these
government-sponsored enterprises what on
earth is that let's just shut them down
and get them out of the housing market
where capital society where free market
society why do we need a government
presence in our in our housing market
but the thing is some of the things we
take for granted as Americans that we
accept his birthright like a 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage wouldn't exist if
you didn't have if you didn't have
institutions that guaranteed that risk
because the financial markets don't
don't want to don't want to absorb it so
when you actually look at the cost of
getting the government out of the
housing market
it becomes it becomes a lot less clear
that that's the right answer
particularly in a day and age where
income inequality is at the top of
everybody's list of the ills in our
society if you didn't have these two
giant companies around or some facsimile
thereof mortgage credit in this company
in this country would be much harder to
come by for people of middle to lower
income it would be much harder to come
by in parts of the country that aren't
as well-off as well-off financially so
when you really dig into this
very clean idea we'll just kill the two
companies and get the government out of
the housing market actually becomes a
lot less a lot less simple and that's
part of the reason why we don't have any
answer to this is it's not ideologically
appealing right because if you're on the
heart right you want to say we'll just
just get rid of them and if you're on
the hard left you might say well let's
just nationalize them and have the
government do do anything and the right
in the government could do everything
and the right answer is probably
somewhere in the middle and probably
actually somewhat close to the system
that we that we had that we had in place
and I think it gets to another sort of
uncomfortable issue which is that a lot
of times in the quest for perfect their
there there is no perfect and you you do
the best you can you muddle through and
you try to put safeguards in place that
will make the system work work for
everybody but I think one of the things
that's holding up the moving forward is
is ideology one the quest for a perfect
which which which may not exist then
just this idea that well the status quo
is is fine it's put that pushing off
making a decision is somehow not a
decision when in reality it is its own
form of decisions how about the
n-c-double-a there there have been some
positive things which have happened in
the wake of kind of all these efforts to
try to reform there's now a concussion
protocol in the n-c-double-a there are
four year scholarships now yeah now
they're I guess factoring in the true
cost of attendance what's what's left to
fix then so there have been a number of
lawsuits and and the union movement at
Northwestern really put a scare into
sort of the status quo but the system
there is a little bit of extra money for
the players now there has been
incremental movement sort of toward
reform but it essentially is is
unchanged and it's really hard to go
through the courts because there was a
suit over using players names and images
in TV without their consent and without
paying them for it and they won and
and appeal the idea that that colleges
could now pay trust funds to players was
overturned while still saying that the
NCAA had violated antitrust laws so in
essence it was the rules are illegal but
they can basically continue as they are
and it's because you know institutions
like the courts and institutions like
the labor board which weighed in on the
northwestern case don't want to hit the
eject button on the system that we have
here and don't want to be the ones who
are blamed for change in college sports
because there are so many college sports
fans and people really like college
sports and so to change fundamentally
change the system that we have I think
you can you mentioned the University of
Missouri and basically what happened is
there were issues of racism on campus
and they had been percolating for weeks
and maybe months and as soon as the
football team set up or stood up and
said we are not going to play on
Saturday until something is done the
university president resigned in 36
hours 36 hours and that is how much
power that the athletes on campuses have
and and schools have given it to them
almost unwittingly because there is so
much money now tied up in the games the
TV money
ESPN CBS and and the concessions and the
sponsorships and so if the game doesn't
go on there is so much money at stake
and so just imagine if if a team didn't
come out for the Final Four and said
we'd like to renegotiate the terms of
how we play college sports I think this
system would change in half an hour it
would change so fast again that's also
really really hard to do because these
are 18 and 19 year old kids who want to
play in the Final Four and so to take a
stand is really hard especially because
many of them are just in college for a
couple years they have a pro career that
they're looking out for but I think that
is what it's going to take to to
fundamentally make the system more
equitable and is it something that
should be fixed not just for big-time
college basketball and football but have
a word
land of lacrosse here in Maryland how
about lacrosse players yeah I think I
think the NCAA rules for all athletes
three things should happen tomorrow that
would make it better for everybody I
think
when you talk about salaries and
actually paying the athletes from the
school I think that's different for the
football and the men's basketball
players because they are fundamentally
on campus to generate revenue for the
school and to be visible and it's
different even than lacrosse at Johns
Hopkins or Maryland but for them I would
say you should get a lifetime
scholarship meaning that you can focus
on your sport while you're in school and
come back and get the education you're
promised whenever you want you should
have lifetime health care so if you ever
get injured competing for your school
the school covers those bills for life
and the third thing is even at Johns
Hopkins or even at a Division three
school if you somebody wants to pay you
money for your autograph
you ought to be able to sell your
autograph if the car dealership wants to
use you two for a commercial to endorse
their cars or if Nike wants to you know
pay you to wear Nike you ought to be
able to have control over your name and
image and and make any money from from a
third-party vendor that you can well I
want to leave some time for audience
questions so why don't I open it up now
and please walk over to the mic if
you've got one and
like sorry
because of television
- MS McLain I know what when I look at
the meltdown of the financial sector in
2008 I think of it in terms of the you
know greatest crime wave in American
history yet nobody went to jail I'm very
interested in what you think of that I
think that's the question everybody is
still asking all these years later and
the fact that people are still asking at
all these years later so that there's
really no satisfactory answer to it
something to give you a couple of
different answers the first one is these
are really these actually are really
white-collar frauds are really hard to
prosecute even Enron which most people
think of as a giant fraud was actually
mostly what I like to refer to as
illegal fraud which is they found ways
to rip off the system and take advantage
of loopholes in the system while meeting
the letter of the law such that when
prosecutors tried to go after it it was
actually very difficult to do it because
it turned out that accountants and
lawyers and all the people in our system
who protect top executives from the
consequences of their decision even when
they benefit even when they profit
directly from those decisions had signed
off on everything making it making it
really really difficult to to prosecute
but difficulty alone isn't the reason
there weren't there weren't convictions
in the wake in the wake of the financial
crisis there wasn't an appetite to do it
and part of that was because nobody
wanted to wreak more havoc on these
institutions that we just bailed out and
there was a very real fear I think that
if there were prosecution's that we
would we would crater the kind of very
fragile confidence in these institutions
that we just spent all this taxpayer
money and all this taxpayer money
bailing out and then I think there's a
third reason in the financial crisis
that is that is really really difficult
which is that the regulator's signed off
on a lot of what was happening so it
adds it goes back to my first
explanation a lot of the things that we
find the most reprehensible that are the
most deeply immoral are not necessarily
illegal and what I dislike about our
modern markets is that it often seems
like these amoral does
aren't punished in other ways you would
like to believe that then there would be
a deeper punishment in the term of
career lost or shame felt if the
punishment can't be legal and our world
doesn't seem to work that way anymore
floor is open presentation I find myself
utterly blown away by the institutional
greed that you have described I know
knew it existed but now I am just
shuttering my question is for Ben
Strauss I have read recently that some
of the problem with college tuitions
exploding is that some of that money is
going toward supporting the sports
portion of the college is that a rumor
is that true and secondly the human face
of the students who are not able to take
advantage of the money the hunger that
they experience I'd like to hear a
little bit more about that the you're
talking about student fees and so there
has been some some coverage of student
fees at the bigger schools we're talking
about the ACC in the SEC in the Big Ten
those the student fees there it's much
more of an issue at smaller schools that
don't have TV money to fall back on or
to to tap to pay for you know the things
that they they want the bigger stadiums
and
you know more facilities and you know
more money for coaches but at some
schools that are not you know Florida
that are not you know USC there are
student fees that that fund athletics
and and you know over four years it can
be as much as a thousand dollars which
you know when you're going into debt to
pay for your college education any more
money you know for the football team you
sort of shake your head at and and you
don't have an option to pay the student
fee it's part of the tuition so at
smaller schools that that is an issue as
far as the human face I could tell you
the story of the prologue in in our book
is a player at the University of
Connecticut a few years ago and he was
investigated by the NCAA for for taking
an impermissible benefit as what they
call it and it's really more about what
happens to his mother and the family
when you're under investigation she was
a single black mother and she had
accepted money for a family fret from a
family friend to go on a recruiting
visit with her son right this is basic
parenting this wasn't a guy who was
trying to steer the player to a specific
school this was sort of a human kindness
yes you can go be a parent and go with
your son on his recruiting trip and the
NCAA sent you know five investigators to
her workplace they took her out of work
and took her to a hotel and interrogated
her for five hours sir like four white
men and she's a single black mother you
know asking her about every single check
that she had written for the past two
years and and having to prove that it
that it was not some sort of unseemly or
you know back-channel money to recruit
her son and so the NCAA and college
sports is one of the very first player
really one of the only places that you
can think of where you're guilty until
you prove your innocence so as soon as
you're under investigation
you cannot play your school suspends you
until you prove that you did nothing
wrong and so this this basis in the
the mother ended up losing her job also
because you know she was under so much
stress and and you know the
investigators went to the friends houses
and friends workplaces asking about
every single you know deposit in her
bank account over the last number of
years and it's sort of insane
to think about you know an institution
being able to do that you know in
America today so that's sort of when you
had the human face of getting
investigated by the NCAA for doing
something that really doesn't seem like
a very big deal and in fact is not a
very big deal and unfortunately that's
just one of many stories like that it
that that Ben and Joe Chronicle in this
book they were that really gets your
blood boiling next question I wanted to
take a different perspective from the
last couple of questions and hope that
nobody throws rotten tomatoes at me but
I'm Bethany as you said it's human
nature to want to blame and to want to
blame the GSEs or to blame the NCAA
administers but the reality is that they
wouldn't have had the power that they
have if we weren't the ones tuning into
the basketball games and the football
games and if we weren't the ones that
loved our houses and want nice houses
and take out loans for home renovation
and so I'm wondering how much each of
your books address the real cultural
nature of of the greed that gets
embedded in these systems I have that
line I sometimes use when I'm talking
about scandals which is that it oh every
every scandal every story of business
gone wrong in some ways always involves
the complicity of the victims because we
all buy into this belief that and
something that after the fact is clearly
going to be seemed too good to be true
and certainly in the financial crisis
homeowners bought into the idea that
home prices would only would only go up
forever and I think I'm a big believer
in personal responsibility without some
sense of personal personal
responsibility were all completely lost
but I also think that what has something
that has gone wrong in our system is
that there isn't a often a corresponding
sense of corporate responsibility I
think
responsibility does have to be a two-way
street and I was firmly on the camp of
this is all the fault of homeowners who
took out mortgages they couldn't afford
until I came upon this presentation from
a big financial institution called
Washington Mutual that talked about how
you persuaded people who really just
wanted a 30-year fixed-rate mortgage to
take out a much riskier loan instead
because the much riskier loan was much
more profitable to Washington Mutual and
they could turn around and sell it to
the to the big banks for much more money
and so it was a script for their sales
people about what you did when someone
came in and said no I really I just want
a safe 30-year fixed-rate mortgage and
how you changed change their mind and so
I think I think to your point we are we
are lost without personal responsibility
and we are all to submit at some extent
complicit in the story of every every
business gone wrong but that doesn't
mean it is all our fault responsibility
has to be a two-way street and there has
to be responsibility from people about
the decisions they make but also
responsibilities from corporations about
the decisions that they they encourage
people to make I think we have time for
just one more question I have a question
for Bethany I am an economist by degree
but I've gotten to the point of not
caring anymore and not following what's
going on in the economic arena talking
about the financial crisis as a simple
taxpayer you mentioned the the guilt of
Fannie and Freddie but you didn't
mention anything about Jeanne how are
they structured now how are my tax
dollars supporting the subsidies that
that is going to these three mega
institutions thank you right so well
right now Fannie and Freddie are
essentially supported by a line of
credit from taxpayers and they've
actually they took a hundred and eighty
seven billion dollars from taxpayers in
the form of their bailout people thought
they would never be able to repay it
they actually have paid almost a hundred
billion dollars more than they took back
into the u.s. the US Treasury and we've
been able to use that to reduce the
budget deficit the big problem with the
way they're structured is that the
taxpayer is
on the hook capital is what absorbs
losses in a financial institution every
financial institution needs capital to
absorb losses from unexpected events
because Fannie and Freddie under under
the direction of the US government are
being drained of all their capital in a
few years they are going to have
absolutely nothing with which to absorb
any unexpected losses so guess where all
those unexpected losses are those losses
that are going to happen because they
happen into every financial institution
go right back to all of us so that's
that's why I believe it's a problem we
need to fix well I think that's just
about all the time we have indentured
the inside story of those who took on
the n-c-double-a I'm converted on shaky
ground the story of the still unsolved
story of the US mortgage giants I'm very
concerned but other than that it's been
a very pleasant experience up here and I
want to say congratulations to you both
and thank you thanks very much